e já é
e aí
e olha é uma mulher forte poderosa e
sagrada dando de tanta beleza rainha
obstinada minha mãe meu orixá é dona da
minha vida estão linda me olhar me
protegeu mãe querida boa tarde eu sou
elaine torres mais conhecida como online
a filha de dona inácia mulher negra
é analfabeta
a empregada doméstica e mãe de 5 filhos
e quando criança minha mãe dizia para
mim todos os dias filha study
é só o estudo pode tirar você dessa vida
e se você estudar
e você vai ser exemplo para crianças
iguais a você hoje eu entendo a mulher
forte e corajosa que era minha mãe
a minha mãe usou de sua sabedoria
popular e de projetos sociais para nos
tirar dos perigos da rua e para ajudar
no zé do carro
esse é o obediente onde vi um projeto
social eu e me inscrevi a eu aprendi a
costurar bordar fazer tricô mais um
projeto social em particular mudou minha
vida
e foi a dança
e quando dançava quando eu gostava o
mundo mudava
e quando eu dançava eu perdi a aquela
sensação de inferioridade que eu tinha
eu sabia que não tinha as mesmas roupas
eu sabia que não tinha os mesmos sapatos
e eu sabia que não frequentava e nem
podia ser aguentar as mesmas escolas mas
quando eu dançava
e quando eu dançava tudo mudava
a e foi a dança que me deu força de
vontade foi a dança que me deu
determinação
e eu soube transferir a determinação da
dança
e para outras áreas da minha vida passei
no colégio a tirar notas altas e aí eu
consegui
a ganhar bolsa de estudo em escolas
particulares e em cursos de informática
nasce então em mim uma vontade uma
vontade de mudar o meu povo de fazer
alguns por eles
é mas infelizmente filho de pobre
precisa trabalhar muito cedo para poder
ajudar nas contas da casa e foi isso que
eu tive que fazer aos 16 anos eu comecei
a trabalhar
eu estudei me casei tive dois filhos
algodão e o mec vocês viram no palco
lindos
eu me separei após a separação meses
depois eu descobri um nódulo no
intestino
eu fiz um tratamento longo e doloroso
é um dia depois do tratamento médico
olhou para mim disse elaine você está
bem vai fazer aquilo que gosta
oi e eu que que eu gosto de fazer vocês
podem me responder eu gosto de dançar
eu resolvi fazer dança de salão na dança
de salão conheci rodrigo meu segundo
marido um apaixonado pela cultura
popular um dia ele acordou e diz
morzinho vou montar o maracatu tomei um
susto e na mesma hora me veio a sensação
eu te ajudo desde que nós possamos
juntos colocar crianças e adolescente
negras e de periferia rodrigo obviamente
topo então saímos por aí divulgando
panfletando atrás de alunos de escola
pública
e vocês sabem alunos de escola pública
são em quase 100 porcento negros e de
periferias conseguimos alguns mike
manuel calado mas aí veio um dia um
menino de 12 anos especial leo leo era
morador de um era filho de uma moradora
de rua
ó e vai pedir para tocar obviamente nós
estamos com o tempo léo precisa morar na
minha casa e vimos a necessidade de
matricular leo em uma escola
e vamos até divino espírito santo
chegando lá encontramos aquele pátio
imenso aquelas crianças correndo e mesmo
sem um recurso sem um instrumento eu e
rodrigo olhamos um para o outro e
descemos para a direção vamos montar o
maracatu aqui na várzea onde moramos
pedimos permissão a direção que
concordou montamos um maracatu
imediatamente 45 crianças foram
inscritas página em algumas delas já
envolvida no tráfico de drogas e no
consumo de maconha álcool e cola
oi e aí mais uma situação difícil o que
que eu vou fazer para controlar e tirar
essas crianças desse caminho
eu fui dormir e acordei com a inspiração
três lições a primeira lição 6 tudo nada
feito para tocar você tem que frequentar
a sala de aula não colégio a sala de
aula melhorar suas notas segunda lição
você é preto lindo essas crianças tinham
auto estima baixa não gostavam de seus
cabelos não gostava da cor de sua pele
através de palestras através de filmes
nós mudamos isso fizemos eles têm honra
orgulho daquele cabelo crespo black da
cor de sua pele e da cor de sua roupa
afro tão colorida tão bonita
e a terceira lição foi a que eu tive lá
atrás quando eu comecei a dançar aquela
sensação de que eu podia passei para
eles a mesma sensação vocês podem vamos
em tocadas
a visitar e tocar na escola na
universidade de direito centro de artes
de pesquisa licenciatura e vimos sonhos
mudar
ah esses meninos antes este um sonhos
simples sonhos humildes de ser em caixas
de supermercado pedreiro e balconista
hoje eles sonham eles sabem que pode
eles são esse advogados eles são e ser
professores eles são e sermos músicos e
sonho inclusive em ser médicos e
oi e aí vem a quarta lição a quarta
lição foi para mim
e eles me ensinaram o poder do afeto o
poder do carinho daquele abraço molhado
depois do jogo de futebol na quadra eles
me ensinaram o poder tão esquecido que
na maioria de vocês esqueceram o da
benção
é aquela hora que a gente chega em casa
e disse bença mãe e ela responde deus te
abençoe minha filha nós esquecemos disso
eu queria aqui deixar duas histórias e
especial a história do menino jean jean
um seguro maracatu muito tímido fechado
ele não ria
e como assim uma adolescente não ri eu
exijo como vocês vem que eles toquem e
riam para plateia eu cobrava de jean
jean não ria um dia meu filho mais velho
chegou para me disse mãe pare por favor
pare de cobrar a jean de rir e cantar eu
tô da bruta diz porque e ele me revela
mãe já não ri porque não tem os dentes
da frente e
eu tomei aquele susto não sabia como
resolver
o jean voltou a tocar que de repente
jean some do maracatu eu mando dezenas
de recados 10 ainda dezenas e me chega a
notícia jean comprou um cavalo
e para vocês aquele pangaré que vive
atrapalhando o trânsito pode não
representar perigo nenhum a não ser se
machucar o seu carro para mim era um
sinal de alerta me diga com vocês como é
que jean conseguiu o dinheiro para
comprar um cavalo com que dinheiro jean
ia manter de ração e remédios
e eu me preocupei e comecei a mandar
recados até que um sábado iluminado
chega jean lá em casa ele e o cavalo
e eu olho para jean e diego jean meu
filho tu me trocaste por um cavalo
oi e ele diz assim
o diário oficial já mal fala gente e aí
eu comecei a falar das possibilidades
que o maracatu podia ter eu nem
imaginava tocar aqui no tédio viu gente
mas eu comecei a falar das
possibilidades que o maracatu podia ter
é mas nada atingiu o coração de jean até
que eu lancei mão do meu sentimento do
amor que eu tinha por jean disse jean
filho volta para o maracatu eu estou
preocupada
oi e a pessoa que se preocupa se
preocupa porque ama quem ama cuida jean
filho volta jean meio que ressabiado
muda o olhar eu vejo um brilho no olhar
de jean
bom e rápido ali a minha esperança jean
filho eu te amo você sabe que eu tenho
você como um filho volta e ele levantou
e vou me embora para casa tomar banho eu
vou tocar já foi para casa quando eu
cheguei lá no recife antigo tava jean e
seu tambor
e o cavalo jean resolveu vendendo para
um carroceiro desse aí da vida
e os dentes de jean nós os adultos do
maracatu nos juntamos e consertamos jean
foi escolhido o melhor batuqueiro no
carnaval de 2018 escreveu o irmão na
oficina
ah e hoje g1 sou rico
g1
a outra história que eu queria contar é
de janaína a menina que sentia vergonha
da cor de sua pele e do seu cabelo
e o dia eu chego na escola e flavinha
uma das professoras nota 10 do país diz
para mim você leu a carta que janaína
inscreveu ainda não e flavinha me mostra
a carta e lá está escrito essas pessoas
não sabem o que falam e nem quanto as
palavras dela dói
e as pessoas do maracatu são diferente
elas fazem eu me sentir linda elas me
fazem ter orgulho de minha cor e do meu
cabelo
e essa carta de janaína foi parar na
maior emissora de televisão do país jana
e ponderada deu entrevista
e lá está janaína minha gente a gente
não consegue com conversas a gente não
consegue com cesta básica
em qual a de rebeca com aula de dança
com aulas de reforço que a gente dá a
gente não consegue salvar todos a gente
não consegue com a dedicação com só do
nosso próprio corpo salvar nós perdemos
arthur perdendo os pelé perdemos
estouram e outros para o tráfico de
droga mas eu sinto no fundo do meu
coração que nós estamos vencendo essa
guerra e eu vou mostrar porque
e o índice de desenvolvimento da
educação básica na escola aumentou
depois da entrada do maracatu de 2 para
3.9 por cento nós conseguimos diminuir a
quase zero o consumo de drogas eo
tráfico de droga na escola violência na
escola eles viviam brigando a violência
na escola caiu muito problemas com pais
gravidez na adolescência e nós prestamos
atenção também naquela menininha
gordinha que vivia se escondendo porque
não estava nos padrões da mídia sim nós
lembramos também dela e aqui eu queria
deixar para vocês uma mensagem uma
filosofia africana o boto
olá eu sou o que nós somos
ah e outra aquela que o grande pai nos
ensinou ama o teu próximo como a si
mesmo
o e muda a tua vida eu mudei a minha
hoje eu estou aqui realizando a profecia
de dona inácia minha mãe sendo exemplo
para as crianças iguais amém
bom e queria deixar vocês com uma
mensagem linda
e a imagem da tocada no teatro de santa
isabel onde nem luiz gonzaga na década
de 60 conseguiu tocar sabe porque era
negro e tocava música popular nós saímos
da rua da guia para várzea da várzea
para o teatro de santa isabel do teatro
de santa isabel para os palcos do ted
dos palcos do ted nós eu tenho certeza
vamos para o mundo do maracá e
e aí
a e agora eu queria pedir a jean jean
vem aqui já
e vem cá
e as palmas vocês não devem a mim as
formas vocês também o jean ele me
ensinou ama ele me ensinou o poder do
afeto
e eu te amo meu bairro e
e aí